Yeah i'm not sure what that's about it's
probably just a case of the mondays am i right
this is our home then let's fight for it
we are an unusual couple it was really so fun
getting to play all these different decades
throughout Wandavision we
just don't know what to expect
and then of course everything kind of breaks
down and becomes an mcu version of the real world
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are can't believe how it just
keeps unraveling and unfolding in ways
that i am still shocked and thrilled by
every day it's something different you know it's
high-tech marvel with helicopters flying around
and the next day it's a perfect recreation of
a 50s sitcom you know some days it's both
i think something's wrong here i think it's
going to be really satisfying for people
when they realize what is at the heart of this
show this is our home then let's fight for it
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision episode 7 trailer video there's
also some footage in here from the last couple
of episodes too from eight and nine so i'll talk
about that too but if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos also
be doing episode videos for falcon and winter
soldier which is gonna start right after the
Wandavision finale or a little while after and
then loki episodes later this year there's a
bunch of big stuff coming up we're also doing the
disney plus giveaway for memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and post all
your predictions for the last couple of episodes
of Wandavision on the video it's only going to
get crazier and crazier as the episodes go on
so obviously spoiler warning for everything
that's happened on the show so far if you
haven't seen the episodes yet but here we have
wanda and tyler hayward both trying to out-carry
each other over the fate of the mcu with her
expanding the hex threatening to expand it even
more potentially covering the entire earth
i know a lot of you are like wait a minute
if she's mutating everyone's dna does that
mean that's how you create mutants in the mcu
i'll address that in a second because there's some
qualifiers that darcy gave when she was talking to
monica rambeau it's a little more complicated than
just passing through the barrier once or twice but
i believe episode 7 just per the footage is going
to be the modern family inspired episode because
we're moving to the 2010s now in the sitcom
decades they also talked about the office when
they were talking about the parodies of sitcoms
they were doing on the show who are you who am i
i'm jim we've been working together for 12 years
so we'll probably see some more easter eggs in the
way they filmed the scenes but also a lot more
of them talking directly to the camera like you
see on modern family or the office like when
we see her sitting there in her pajamas in the
middle of the day talking about how she's totally
fine i'm fine when she's clearly not fine then
starts talking about having a case of the mondays
although it's not clear when she's talking about
the quote-unquote case of the mondays if she's
just referencing the end of episode six where
things got really crazy vision died for the third
time kind of and she just expanded the barrier
turning the sword base all the sword agents
including darcy into circus versions of themselves
although i think of all these new hex versions of
the sword agents i think we're all just most hyped
up to see what role she cast darcy in since kat
dennings in real life did sitcoms for a long time
and i know there were a lot of questions after
the big quick silver twist with evan peters
in episode six what she's capable of when she
rewrites people and what she's not capable of
like can she give people powers when she rewrites
them just because it was so twisty with the way
they explained the quicksilver character but
then you see the other new footage from that
same episode with her in the pajamas changing the
living room on the fly like she doesn't like the
way it looks so she changes it but then getting
really surprised and scared when she looks around
the room and sees the entire house just glitching
out changing uncontrollably while this is all
going on obviously her just slowly continuing
to lose it mentally tyler hayward also seems
like he's starting to lose it in the real world at
the same rate but he seems like he's a hot second
away from ordering a full-blown nuclear strike
on westview new jersey can't you just picture
nick fury on the sword station in outer space
just glaring down at all this like i'm on vacation
please just stop trying to destroy the earth for
a week or two although i know there are a lot of
questions about what's happening with the other
avengers how come they aren't stepping in to help
where's nick fury why isn't he helping out at
this point right now after avengers end game
it's probably talos on earth masquerading as nick
fury remember the events of spider-man far from
home take place about eight months after avengers
end game but right now on Wandavision we're still
only three weeks after end game in the way the
russos and john watts the director of spider-man
far from home and spider-man 3 said that talos
didn't start pretending to be nick fury till
after iron man's funeral that was real nick fury
there at his funeral then at some point really
soon after this he heads up to the sword space
station and talos starts acting as a stand-in
there's a whole bunch of other scroll stuff that
they teased during spider-man far from home that
they'll get into during the nick fury secret
invasion tv series i know because tyler hayward
is kind of being positioned as one of the villains
of Wandavision at least one of the antagonists
there are all kinds of theories about him secretly
being a scroll or somebody else masquerading as a
person in control of sword i know during episode
six they made a couple nightmare references
quakesilver evan peters quicksilver made a
nightmare reference and then tyler hayward
in the real world also made another nightmare
reference and people are expecting nightmare to
be the villain of doctor strange too so people are
just wondering if maybe nightmare has something to
do with what's happening with everything spiraling
out of control on Wandavision that's still
possible obviously they did confirm Wandavision
will cross over with doctor strange too but i
think most of that is going to wind up happening
in the actual finale and will be connected to the
the big super cameo that they've been hyping up
for the past couple of weeks even though evan
peters quicksilver showing up is a pretty big
cameo but i still think that the special cameo
that they've been talking about is something even
bigger and they wouldn't blow it on the show when
we're only about halfway through the episodes
i think it'll still be something for the finale
but the other new footage we see is monica rambeau
piloting that special tank-looking vehicle with
our air force helmet back into the hex as we last
saw them speeding away from the barrier of the hex
as it was expanding they were on their way to meet
that mystery engineer that was going to create the
new vehicle monica's guy a lot of theories about
who that is but i don't think that it's supposed
to be reed richards i've seen so many people
speculating about fantastic four on social media i
would love for it to be a fantastic four character
but right now the way that kevin feige explains
it he hasn't cast any of those fantastic four
characters yet so even though people would love
for like john krasinski to be mr fantastic in the
mcu when you see people posting is she going to
go meet john krasinski is going to show up on the
tv show that's probably not going to happen it's
more likely that the character she's going to meet
this mystery person is someone more connected to
sword and monica rambeau in the comics and captain
marvel through the captain marvel 2 movie because
a lot of monica rambeau's story is tied to captain
marvel 2. it's like all setting up what's going to
be happening with her character in the future the
mcu also monica rambeau per darcy's explanation
will have her dna mutate big time again when
she travels through the barrier for a third time
for people that were confused about this she
passed through the barrier twice already once
on the way in at the beginning of the show then
a second time when she was getting kicked out
the whole explainer that darcy gave for how
scarlet witch's hex alters people's dna rewrites
it on a cellular level is probably one of the
mcu explainers for mutants being created though
mutants in the mcu but i don't think that means
that every single person in westview new jersey
is going to walk away from Wandavision being a
mutant now just because they were inside the hex
like darcy got sucked in now and she's being
rewritten as one of the circus people or
somebody else in this new scenario for episode
seven but remember the key here in who becomes
mutants and who doesn't i think has more to do
with how many times their dna gets messed with
like the way darcy was talking about it monica
was already a little bit different you need to
be careful because if you go back in then you
might go full blown mutant so like right now
when they're speeding away going to meet her guy
the special engineer she's not full-blown photon
from the comics yet but clearly they're hyping
that up because all the merch all the posters
they've released have her wearing very modern day
looking versions of her photon costume i think
the real threat of the hex right now as she's
expanding it to save vision is that eventually
or potentially she'd probably be able to expand it
across the entire world and rewrite everyone and
everything full-blown house of m style and that's
the scenario where you'd see everybody potentially
turn into mutants with the exception of probably
the most powerful people like doctor strange
thor the hulk maybe i think it really depends on
how powerful you are like if doctor strange winds
up showing up in the finale scarlet witch's power
probably wouldn't be able to affect him quite as
much as it affects the regular townspeople all the
footage of them in the sweats and vision outside
in his normal avengers costume looking like he's
getting into a fight that might be from the last
two episodes from eight and nine because i'm
assuming episode seven is probably going to be
the last sitcom decade and after that we go back
to full movie aspect ratio and as far as evan
peters quicksilver we saw her like blast him and
just kick him to the side after he was sassing her
too much at the end of the episode when visions
life was being threatened i think depending on how
they addressed pietro at the beginning of episode
seven that will absolutely confirm what was really
going on with him whether or not he was really
just a big fake out cameo like a one-off thing for
those of you wondering whether or not they intend
on bringing evan peters quicksilver fully into
the mcu permanently i think a lot of people were
hoping that it was going to be a big multiverse
twist and the way they explained it was just way
more of a mind screw way more twisty just based on
the way he was talking during the episode and the
way they passed it off i'm not expecting the way
he was performing quicksilver here in the episode
to fully come into the mcu permanently and replace
aaron taylor johnson quicksilver he kept making
all these references to special one-off cameo
episodes making it sound like it was just meant
to be a small special thing and i did a video
last week after the writer said that they wanted
to use evan peters just to mind screw the audience
with moments as much as possible like we want to
have a quick silver moment but what's the craziest
version of this we can do they didn't say anything
about him permanently sticking around on the show
but like i said episode 7 should completely
answer all those questions once and for all
they also have the new footage of scarlet witch in
color like in the full movie aspect ratio breaking
into the sword headquarters to steal vision's body
so we might see that as a flashback in episode
7 or it might be from the last two episodes just
revealing what was actually going on with vision's
body in tyler hayward at sword i think the way
that they've been setting this up the tyler
hayward character spinning going off the rails at
the same rate the scarlet witch is going off the
rails we'll find out that tyler hayward was doing
shady stuff with vision's body and she wasn't just
stealing vision's body she was also kind of
rescuing him from sword and tyler hayward and
i know there's still a ton of questions about
what's going on with the future of billy and
tommy in the mcu wicken and speed why are the
twins different and why can't she control them
like she controls everything else inside the
hex part of it has to do with i think the fact
she gave birth to them she didn't just reskin
other bodies from westview to make them like
she does with everyone else i think when we're
talking about multiverse connections because
this is also supposed to connect to spider-man 3
and there's all this implied spider-verse stuff
with tobey maguire andrew garfield spider-man i
think that has more to do with what she's doing
inside the hex because it acts kind of like an
alternate reality and i think that also kind
of gets into what's happening with her children
because billy and tommy are a little bit different
in the way the showrunners and the other mcu
people have talked they'll stick around long term
eventually and we'll see older versions of them
show up in young avengers projects or crossovers
and other disney plus series i think that's where
doctor strange comes in because he has a more
fundamental understanding of how the multiverse
works and what might be going on here so he might
have something to do with helping her figure out a
way to keep the children and make them stick when
the hex comes down so everyone just post all your
theories in the comments below in my full episode
7 video we'll post next friday just like normal
but i'll be doing bonus videos for some of the
other stuff before then too there's also a really
big justice league snyder cut trailer that's going
to drop tomorrow so of course i'll do a video for
that as well but if you have any big questions or
easter eggs or things you're confused about you
want me to do bonus videos for just let me know
in the comments while you wait for everything
click here for my full Wandavision episode six
and quicksilver video and click here for that
brand new falcon in winter soldier trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!